every time you see a good film it sort
of helps recall all the other good films
that you've always seen Tutsi Bible
rocket Bulworth why not this the social
club The Matrix cava girl Shirley Temple
honey Schwarzenegger really Christie
Martina Dietrich movies are an escape
just an escape well what's wrong with
that that's quite a lot I'd rather go to
a mediocre movie and a good plain movies
are like food they're essential to your
life
postman rang twice did you see that one
hearts and minds which won an Academy
Award and maybe stopped the war in
Vietnam can movies really do that that
one did you learn how to be sexy after I
thought I knew I had to wear a
three-piece white suit to my bar mitzvah
I liked Bad Lieutenant which was sort of
a dark seamy side of the police but I
liked Harvey Keitel even in my country
when I lived there I used to see all the
classic American movies what I did get
out of movies was that there was a
better life than that life that I was
leading lizzle founded by [ __ ] Fast
Times at Ridgemont High mom I'm leaving
I'm going to Hollywood and I'm going to
marry Rhett Butler what about Bob she
was picked out by Patrick Swayze the
most handsome guy in the room she's not
expecting anybody to even notice her
they both love each other and then he
goes and dies and it's the most
frustrating thing in the world and
Ernest goes to jail it's unfair life's
unfair and Ernest goes to jail tells us
that not taps tap taps was the army
flick it was extraordinarily evocative
even though I never saw the movie
operation Tokyo flying monkey the little
dog
they got mommy her eyes were big and
brown
Asha's seeing King Kong try and conquer
New York and getting shot down that was
the deal
the movie is playing a game with you and
it's a game you're happy to play Redrum
Redrum The Omen Uncle Buck Braveheart a
scene 150 times they can make you proud
they could make you perhaps a little
ashamed skateboard movies The African
Queen Brazil giant all of his ambitions
have been thwarted except of course that
big whale that comes in i'ma sit and he
squeezes his face love story no wire
hangers ever adjourn godzilla vs. Mothra
not the Remo no not at all those
terrible movies can't help us look into
the inner soul of people how could we
survive without movies faster pussycat
kill kill Love Me Tender sunny and
heartwarming gruff uncompromising
something with squirrels I would imagine
this world honor and service and duty
and pity and black and white flickering
God I'm into this second row or third
row I like being overwhelmed by it
sometimes we numb ourselves to reality
movies kind of bring it back for us
maybe that's what we need to learn in
the world is don't leave your seat let's
wait to the end of the movie and work it
out know what logic are yeah yeah
you're attacking right Oh
and I liked the gladiator with Russell
Crowe in the wagon it takes her back to
the country sort of rode off into the
sunset yeah that's a good word Warren
the front page Breakfast Club 10 drops
sexy B's Lawrence of Arabia Sundays and
meet me in sync you love them honestly
Holy Grail I in the Opera hey waiter on
the Dingell Citizen Kane can't believe
all the jazz singer bicycle on the Beast
a Battle of Algiers unload James Bond
blue Godfather on for my father money
talks with Mary Thomas I'm not sure that
it's a dramatic medium it sort of
belongs more to poetry than it does to
anything else
in the end everybody comes with money
and the angel gets waiting said it's
just it completely redeems the idea of
being good so that's why I think I like
it